SWAMP.
>> Tucker: I WILL BE THERE.
>> Sean: WISH EVERYBODY THE
BEST FROM ME.
BREAKING JUST TONIGHT
DOCUMENTS JUST OBTAINED BY
JUDICIAL WATCH SHOW GUESS
WHAT THE PIT BULL OF ROBERT
MUELLER, ANDREW WEISSMAN, HE
WAS TOPPED BY MUELLER TO
LEAD THE ENTIRE HIRING
EFFORT FOR THE SPECIAL
COUNSEL'S WITCH-HUNT.
THAT'S RIGHT THE ANDREW
WEISSMAN OF ALL PEOPLE.
NOW WE KNOW WHY MUELLER'S
TEAM WAS FILLED WITH, OH,
FAR LEFT CLINTON ALLIES,
ZERO REPUBLICAN DONORS.
AFTER ALL, THE SAME ANDREW
WEISSMAN, HE WAS ATTENDING
HILLARY CLINTON'S ELECTION
NIGHT PARTY THAT NEVER
HAPPENED.
BUT THE SAME PARTISAN HACK
WHO DONATED THOUSANDS OF
DOLLARS TO DEMOCRATS.
THE SAME GUY ACCORDING TO
SIDNEY POWELL'S BOOK
LICENSED TO LIE, KNOWN FOR
WITHHOLDING EXCULPATORY
EVIDENCE, TENS OF THOUSANDS
OF JOBS WERE LOST AT
ANDERSON ACCOUNTING BECAUSE
OF HIS WRONGFUL PROSECUTION
IN THE CASE.
REMEMBER THAT CASE WAS
OVERTURNED 9-0.
WHY DID MUELLER HIRE THIS
GUY IN THE U.S. SUPREME
COURT?
DON'T FORGET HE IS THE GUY
WHO PUT FOUR MERRILL
EXECUTIVES IN JAIL FOR A
YEAR.
THAT CASE WAS OVERTURNED BY
THE FIFTH CIRCUIT.
ONE YEAR OF FOUR PEOPLE'S
LIVES RUINED.
YET BOB MUELLER APPOINTED
HIM TO BE THE MOST POWERFUL
PERSON IN THIS ENTIRE
WITCH-HUNT INVESTIGATION
WHICH AT THE END OF THE DAY,
FRANKLY, IN RETROSPECT,
GIVES SO MUCH MORE WEIGHT TO
THE FACT THAT THEY FOUND
NOTHING.
NOW, MAKE NO MISTAKE,
MUELLER'S HYPERPARTISAN TEAM
OF INVESTIGATORS, THEY WERE
HELL BENT ON TAKING DOWN A
DULY ELECTED PRESIDENT OF
THE UNITED STATES.
THEY WERE NO DIFFERENT THAN
MANY OTHER HIGH RANKING
UNELECTED GOVERNMENT
BUREAUCRATS.
SEVERAL DOCUMENTS
SURROUNDING DOJ OFFICIAL
BRUCE OHR AND STATE
DEPARTMENT OFFICIAL KATHLEEN
CAV LACK.
KEEP IN MIND CAVLACK AND OHR
MET WITH CHRISTOPHER STEELE.
TO THE FBI, TO THE DOJ PRIOR
TO THAT FIRST FISA WARRANT
APPLICATION AGAINST CARTER
PAGE TO SPY ON THE TRUMP
CAMPAIGN.
AND STILL AFTER THE
ELECTION, DOCUMENTS NOW SHOW
THAT OHR AND CAV LACK WERE
STILL OBSESSED WITH USING
THE DOSSIER.
THEY KNEW IT WAS PHONY TO
TAKE THE PRESIDENT DOWN.
ON NOVEMBER 21st, 2016.
CAVLACK EMAILING OHR A LINK
TO A MOTHER JONES LEFT WING
MAGAZINE ARTICLE BASED ON
THE PHONY HILLARY BOUGHT AND
PAID FOR RUSSIAN DOSSIER.
OHR EMAILED BACK QUOTE I
REALLY HOPE WE CAN GET
SOMETHING GOING HERE.
WE WILL TAKE ANOTHER LOOK AT
THIS.
SUBSEQUENT CONSPIRATORIAL
EMAIL TO OHR, CAVLACK GAVE A
REFERENCE TO MEETING NOTES
WITH CHRISTOPHER STEELE, 10
DAYS BEFORE THE FIRST FISA
APPLICATION IS PUT IN.
HE IS POLITICAL.
NOT VETTED.
NOBODY VERIFIED.
FROM THE DOJ TO THE STATE
DEPARTMENT TO THE FBI IN ALL
AREAS OF OBAMA'S GOVERNMENT
WERE TOTALLY OBSESSED WITH
CHRISTOPHER STEELE AND HIS
CLINTON PAID FOR RUSSIAN
PROPAGANDA.
SO OBSESSED THAT THEY USED
CLINTON'S HIT MAN THERE HE
IS BACK SAID VICIOUS
BLUMENTHAL TO CORROBORATE
THE DOSSIER IN THEIR FISA
REQUEST.
THE BIGGEST CLINTON PARTISAN
HACK TO CORROBORATE A
CLINTON OP. RESEARCH TO SPY
ON A MEMBER OF THE TRUMP
CAMPAIGN?
WATCH THIS.
>> I HAVE SEEN EACH FACTUAL
ASSERTION LISTED IN THAT
DOSSIER.
AND THEN I HAVE SEEN THE
FBI'S JUSTIFICATION.
AND WHEN YOU ARE CITING
NEWSPAPER ARTICLES AS
CORROBORATION FOR A FACTUAL
ASSERTION THAT YOU HAVE
MADE, YOU DON'T NEED AN FBI
AGENT TO GO DO A GOOGLE
SEARCH.
AND WHEN THE NAME SIDNEY
BLUMENTHAL IS INCLUDED AS
PART OF YOUR CORROBORATION,
AND YOU ARE THE WORLD'S
LEADING LAW ENFORCEMENT
AGENCY, YOU HAVE A PROBLEM.
AND YOU CAN BLAME IT ON THE
FISA COURT IF YOU WANT TO,
BUT I HOPE BRENNAN IS SMART
ENOUGH TO KNOW JUDGES DON'T
INVESTIGATE.
THEY HAVE TO RELY ON THE
HONEST WORD OF THE PEOPLE
PRESENTING IT TO THEM AND IF
THAT HONEST WORD IS MISSING,
THEN THE JUDGE IS GOING TO
MAKE THE WRONG DECISION.
>> Sean: REMEMBER, WE TOLD
YOU THE TOP OF THE FISA
APPLICATION SAYS VERIFIED.
IT'S UNVERIFIABLE.
NOW, FORMER CONGRESSMAN
GOWDY HAS SEEN THE FBI'S
FISA REQUEST AGAINST CARTER
PAGE.
HE KNOWS THAT SAID VICIOUS
BLUMENTHAL AND SIR COULD
BLUMENTHAL AND CIR COULD
BLUMENTHAL AND CIRCUOULD
BLUMENTHAL AND CIRCULALD
BLUMENTHAL AND CIRCULARD
REPORTING REMEMBER MICHAEL
ISIKOFF, SAME SOURCING, THEY
ACTED AS THOUGH IT WAS
SEPARATE SOURCING.
THEY BOTH USED TO BOLSTER
THE UNVERIFIED GARBAGE THAT
COMEY SWORE WAS TRUE TO THE
BEST OF HIS KNOWLEDGE AND
VERIFIED.
NOW, WITH THE INVESTIGATIONS
FROM HOROWITZ AND NOW
MR. DURHAM AS WELL ARE
UNDERWAY.
RUSH LIMBAUGH RIGHTLY
POINTING OUT THE DEEP STATE
IS NOW IN A PANIC MODE FOR
GOOD REASON.
TAKE A LOOK.
>> THE NEXT THING TO KEEP A
SHARP EYE OUT FOR, FOLKS,
AND THAT IS PEOPLE FLEEING
THE COUNTRY.
IF YOU SEE JAMES COMEY IN
ARGENTINA, IF YOU SEE JAMES
CLAPPER SOMEWHERE WHERE THEY
CAN'T BE EXTRADITED, THEN
YOU WILL KNOW THAT WE ARE
GETTING CLOSE.
WHEN THESE PEOPLE START
LEAVING, I'M HALF JOKING.
IT HASN'T STARTED YET.
BUT MAN ARE THEY NERVOUS
BECAUSE THE ATTORNEY GENERAL
HAS APPOINTED A PROSECUTOR
TO LOOK INTO THE
INVESTIGATION.
>> Sean: ALL RIGHT.
NOW THAT'S FUNNY.
I WISH I THOUGHT OF THAT
WHEN YOU SEE THEM IN
VENEZUELA.
ALL RIGHT.
IT'S NOW EVERY MAN, EVERY
WOMAN FOR THEMSELVES AND BY
THE WAY THE CIRCULAR FIRING
SQUAD I TOLD YOU ABOUT LAST
NIGHT IS FORMING.
AND THAT INCLUDES THE
PARAGON OF VIRTUE HIMSELF
MR. JAMES COMEY.
IS HE BLAMING FORMER CIA
DIRECTOR JOHN BRENNAN FOR
PUSHING THE DOSSIER AS,
QUOTE, CROWN MATERIAL.
BUT AS FOX NEWS IS
REPORTING, THAT BRENNAN AND
CLAPPER, THEY ARE ACTUALLY
BLAMING COMEY, CLAIMING THAT
THE PAIR ALWAYS OPPOSED THE
FIRED FBI DIRECTOR'S USE OF
THE DIRTY DOSSIER.
AT THIS POINT THE ONLY THING
THAT COMEY, CLAPPER AND
BRENNAN SEEM TO AGREE ON ARE
THE SEMANTICS SURROUNDING
THE TERM SPYING WHICH, BY
THE WAY, DID OCCUR IN SPITE
OF WHAT THEY ARE SAYING
AGAINST THE TRUMP CAMPAIGN
AND IT HAPPENED NOT ONCE,
NOT TWICE, BUT MULTIPLE
TIMES.
OVER AND OVER AGAIN.
BUT, ACCORDING TO COMRADE
BRENNAN, YES, COMRADE
BRENNAN IT DIDN'T REALLY
HAPPEN.
THE TRUTH IS NOT THE TRUTH.
WE ARE LIVING IN THIS, YOU
KNOW, ALICE IN WONDERLAND OF
JOHN BRENNAN.
TAKE A LOOK.
>> DOES CIA SPY?
YES.
DO WE SPY AGAINST FOREIGN
ADVERSARIES?
YES.
DO WE SPY AGAINST DOMESTIC
INDIVIDUALS?
NO, WE DO NOT.
WE WORK VERY CLOSELY WITH
THE FBI.
AND IN THAT ELECTION AND TO
CHANGE THE OUTCOME OF IT IN
THEIR FAVOR, WE CIA, AND FBI
WORK FOR COLLABORATIVELY SO
THAT WE COULD HAVE THAT
ABILITY TO SEE WHAT THE
RUSSIANS WERE DOING AND WHO
THEY WERE WORKING WITH SO
WHEN WILLIAM BARR SAID
SPYING IT CLEARLY INDICATED
THAT THERE WAS SOMETHING
THAT WAS INAPPROPRIATE IF
NOT ILLEGAL.
NOBODY USED THE TERM SPYING
WHEN THEY ARE REFERRING TO
LEGITIMATE PREDICATED,
AUTHORIZED INVESTIGATIVE
ACTIONS ON THE PART OF THE
FBI.
>> Sean: HE IS LYING.
BUT, OF COURSE, FAKE NEWS,
CONSPIRACY TV WOULDN'T ASK
HIM A QUESTION.
BRENNAN SPIED.
THEY SPIED ON THE TRUMP
CAMPAIGN.
THEY SPIED ON CARTER PAGE.
THEY SPIED ON PAPADOPOULOS.
THEY SPIED ON SAM CLOVIS.
THERE WAS SPYING ALL OVER
THE PLACE WEAPONIZING THE
POWERFUL TOOLS OF
INTELLIGENCE.
BY THE WAY DIDN'T BRENNAN
SEEM AWFULLY DEFENSIVE FOR
SOMEONE WHO HAS DONE NOTHING
WRONG?
ONE FORMER FEDERAL
PROSECUTOR NOW OPENLY
WONDERING WHY BRENNAN IS SO
WORRIED ABOUT THE ONGOING
INVESTIGATION INTO THE
ORIGINS OF THE RUSSIAN
PROBE.
LET'S TAKE A LOOK.
>> IF WHAT DIRECTOR BRENNAN
IS SAYING IS TRUE, THEN
WHAT'S HE WORRIED ABOUT?
BUT, TO HEAR THEM TALK ABOUT
LIKE IT'S A FISHING
EXPEDITION, AFTER WE JUST
HAD A TWO-YEAR INVESTIGATION
OF THE ADMINISTRATION UNDER
CIRCUMSTANCES WHERE THE
JUSTICE DEPARTMENT DIDN'T
ARTICULATE A CRIME THAT IT
WAS ACTUALLY LOOKING AT?
WE SPENT TWO YEARS ON A
FISHING EXPEDITION UNDER THE
GUISE OF COLLUSION?
THEY ARE NOW GOING TO
COMPLAIN ABOUT OVERSIGHT OF
THE INTELLIGENCE AND THE
JUSTICE DEPARTMENT AND THE
FBI?
THAT SEEMS RIDICULOUS TO ME.
>> OF COURSE ANDY IS RIGHT.
BRENNAN, COMEY, CLAPPER,
STRZOK, PAGE, OTHERS HAVE A
LOT OF REASONS TO BE WORRIED
TONIGHT THE TRUMP CAMPAIGN
WAS SPIED ON AT THE HEIGHT
OF A PRESIDENTIAL ELECTION
AT THE DIRECTION OF THE
HIGHEST RANKING BUREAUCRATS
ALL WHO HATED DONALD TRUMP.
SOME WHO RIGGED AN
INVESTIGATION INTO HIS
OPPONENT AND GOT HER OFF THE
HOOK WHEN SHE OBVIOUSLY
COMMITTED CRIMES.
INCLUDING OBSTRUCTION.
NOW, FRAUD AGAINST A FISA
COURT WAS PREMEDITATED AND
COMMITTED BY THESE SAME
OFFICIALS.
AFTER A THREE ROY YEAR
WITCH-HUNT CONDUCTED INTO
ALL THINGS TRUMP BECAUSE OF
RUSSIAN DISINFORMATION
BOUGHT AND PAID FOR
IRONICALLY BY HILLARY
CLINTON, WELL, THIS WASN'T
JUST BAD, IT'S CRIMINAL.
ALL WILL BE HELD
ACCOUNTABLE.
BUT NOT IF DELUSIONAL TRUMP
HATERS ON THE LEFT GET THEIR
WAY.
THEY HAVE THIS PSYCHOTIC
ANTI-TRUMP RAGE THAT IS
BUILT INSIDE THEM.
INSIDE THE DEMOCRATIC PARTY.
AND THEIR NUMBER ONE FANS,
THE MEDIA MOB IS NOW AT
ALL-TIME HIGH.
THEY ARE DESTRUCTIVE.
THEY ARE VENGEFUL HOPES AND
DREAMS HAVE TOTALLY FALLEN
FLAT.
THEY ARE FLOUNDERING ALL OF
THEM.
THE MUELLER WITCH-HUNT CAME
UP EMPTY.
THE TRUMP AGENDA IS WORKING
AND BREAKING RECORDS EVERY
SINGLE SOLITARY DAY.
GOOD NEWS FOR THE COUNTRY, I
GUESS THAT'S BAD NEWS
POLITICALLY FOR THOSE THAT
DISLIKE THE PRESIDENT.
THE ECONOMY IS BOOMING AND
SETTING RECORDS.
THE PRESIDENT'S APPROVAL
NUMBERS ARE REACHING
ALL-TIME HIGHS.
AND IN A SIGN OF SHEAR
DESPERATION, DEMOCRATS ON
CAPITOL HILL ARE FOCUSING
NEARLY 100 PERCENT OF ALL
THEIR EFFORTS ON
RE-LITIGATING,
REINVESTIGATING THE MUELLER
PROBE.
FOUR SEPARATE OCCASIONS.
NO COLLUSION, NO COLLUSION,
NO COLLUSION, NONE
WHATSOEVER.
AND IN A LETTER TO THE HOUSE
JUDICIARY CHAIRMAN JERRY
NADLER, THE WHITE HOUSE
COUNSEL THREW DOWN THE
GAUNTLET WRITING, QUOTE:
CONGRESSIONAL INVESTIGATIONS
ARE INTENDED TO OBTAIN
INFORMATION TO AID IN THE
EVALUATING POTENTIAL
LEGISLATION, NOT TO HARASS
POLITICAL OPPONENTS OR TO
PURSUE AN UNAUTHORIZED
DO-OVER OF EXHAUSTIVE LAW
ENFORCEMENT INVESTIGATIONS
CONDUCTED BY THE DEPARTMENT
OF JUSTICE.
AND I WILL ADD THE FBI.
AND I WILL ADD THE HOUSE
INTEL COMMITTEE.
AND I WILL ADD THE
BIPARTISAN SENATE COMMITTEE.
NADLER IS REQUESTING A WIDE
RANGE OF DOCUMENTS RELATED
TO MUELLER'S INVESTIGATION
AFTER VOTING TO HOLD THE
ATTORNEY GENERAL BARR IN
CONTEMPT.
WHY?
BECAUSE THE ATTORNEY GENERAL
REFUSED TO BREAK FEDERAL
LAW.
HE REFUSED TO REVEAL GRAND
JURY INFORMATION IN THE
SPECIAL COUNSEL'S REPORT.
BECAUSE IF THE ATTORNEY
GENERAL DID, THESE GENIUS
LAWMAKERS WHAT THEY ASKED
HIM TO DO, HE WOULD BE IN
TROUBLE LEGALLY.
AND MEANWHILE CONGRESSMAN,
THE COWARDLY SCHIFF HIMSELF
IS BUSY OBSESSING ABOUT
PHANTOM CLAIMS STILL OF
OBSTRUCTION.
HE HAS NEVER MENTIONED
HILLARY AND SUBPOENAED
EMAILS AND BLEACH BIT AND
HAMMERS.
I WONDER WHY.
HE IS THE CHAIRMAN OF THE
HOUSE INTEL COMMITTEE.
HE IS SUPPOSED TO HELP KEEP
OUR COUNTRY SAFE FROM
THREATS ABROAD.
BUT, YET, HE WANTS A FIFTH
INVESTIGATION INTO A
NONEXISTENT CRIME.
NOT COMMITTED BY ANYBODY
LIKE THE PRESIDENT OF THE
UNITED STATES.
IT'S NOT JUST SCHIFF AND
IT'S NOT JUST NADLER TOTALLY
PREOCCUPIED BY THE WAY WITH
THESE CONSPIRACY THEORIES.
OTHER DEMOCRATS, THEY ARE
BUSY, WASTING YOUR TAX MONEY
WITH AN UPCOMING -- THEY ARE
GOING TO DO A 12-HOUR LONG
DRAMATIC READING OF THE FULL
448 PAGE MUELLER REPORT.
CAN'T WAIT TO SEE THE C-SPAN
RATINGS FOR THIS
EXTRAVAGANZA.
IT IS A SAD STATE OF AFFAIRS
INSIDE THE DEMOCRATIC PARTY.